do you have any closing advice for
comics out there
what can you bestow us with I would say
a be patient it takes a while
it absolutely takes a while B create all
the time and and not just writing
stand-up but find something that you're
good at and create that whether it is
you know and don't just do something
because it worked for someone else you
know you don't watch this and be like oh
I can handle hecklers it's like if you
can great but if not maybe you should do
a web series maybe you should do vlogs
maybe you know maybe you should host a
podcast maybe you shouldn't just because
it worked for someone else we I guess
although advice boils down to one thing
every day we strive to be original on
stage being a hack is the worst thing in
this business but so many people are
hacks offstage hmm there are so many
people who they're promo their web
presence their social media it's all
done because they saw someone else do it
imagine if you're gonna write a joke
because you saw someone else write a
joke that same way so figure out every
comedian is creative every comedian is
intelligent you can't be a comedian
unless you're those things so be
creative intelligent be creative and
intelligent offstage and that will help
free up the space to be those things on
stage alright the final thing we end
with could you look into the camera let
them know who you are and why they
should listen to hot breath hey I'm
Steve Hofstetter and listen to hot
breath because I just told you to I
think I haven't seen any other episodes
but I'm sure they're great alright Steve
thanks to be on hot breath my man thank
you very much
have fun up there thanks there you go
hot breath averse Steve Hofstetter hey
hot brother and sister if you love
comedy as much as we do here at hot
breath click the subscribe button to
join the hot breath averse and then
watch more videos to get even more
comedy tips